- Restaurant Strandhaus,
Grote-Vallée, schönen guten Tag!
Hallo, Herr Butzbach!
Morgen? Für wie viele Personen?
Zwei Personen, das klappt.
Um welche Uhrzeit möchten
Sie kommen morgen?
19 Uhr, okay.
So, der Name war Butzbach mit tz?
Ja, wie ist der Vorname?
Bruno.
Dann bräuchte ich noch
eine Telefonnummer, Herr Butzbach.
0176, ja, 48, alles klar.
Hab ich dann drin:
morgen Abend 19 Uhr für zwei Personen.
Alles klar, bis morgen. Tschüss.
- Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
- Hatten Sie einen Tisch bestellt?
- Ja, für zwei Personen.
- Auf welchen Namen?
- Butzbach.
- Alles klar. Möchten Sie drinnen
oder lieber draußen sitzen?
- Gerne draußen.
- Ja, ist dann einmal hier vorne.
Kommen Sie bitte mit.
- Danke.